we have a couple of major breaking
stories that unfortunately are not
positive stories to discuss with you
today and at the end of this segment
we're gonna have a sort of more general
conversation about this that I predict I
predict many people won't like but for
different reasons first a police officer
that may or may not have been off duty
at the time shot and killed
Russ's ambassador to Turkey Andrei
carlav on video yelling Allahu Akbar
meaning god is great
do not forget Aleppo do not forget Syria
do not forget Aleppo do not forget Syria
as he opened fire a completely shocking
incident it was caught on video as the
Russian ambassador to Turkey was killed
again named Andre Karloff we we have
video that I'm not going to play it's
not particularly gory but it's
everywhere it's easy to find and we've
made the call not not to play the video
here although I'm not against playing
these types of videos but we aren't
going to be playing it today very very
easy to find CNN initially reported that
the officer was off duty at the time of
the shooting
but Turkish government statements sort
of vague about that they left his duty
status at the time of this incident
unclear russia's Foreign Ministry is
calling this a terror attack and of
course the connection between Russia and
Aleppo is that Russia has been very
involved in helping Syrian President
Bashar al-assad and his regime try to
take back the eastern part of Aleppo
that part of Aleppo
had been held by rebel groups for the
last four years and we we have here a
gunman estimated to be a 22 or 23 years
old killed during this attack according
to multiple news agencies including
Reuters we have a number of different
angles here that must be discussed
number one think about what this means
in general for Diplomatic Security local
police often work hand in hand or in
partnership with Secret Service and
equivalent organizations from different
countries including when the United
States president goes abroad and I've
thought about this many times
what protocols are in place to ensure
that no one from the local country's law
enforcement or security may be
compromised or whatever the case may be
many of those individuals armed and
ultimately Pat I don't know that you can
100% prevent some kind of rogue foreign
security or law enforcement person from
doing something like this yeah I don't
think you can and I think it goes
without saying that the crisis in Aleppo
as bad as it is should not be a
justification for you to commit and act
a vigilante justice no but I'm worried
that this will actually be
counterproductive and will leverage
Russia in a way to gain sympathy for
their policy in Syria well there's been
questions about Russian retaliation
right assuming that this is indeed a
terrorist attack that suggests that
Russia would not do anything militarily
to turkey because again a terrorist
attack is not an act by a country but
there's another wrinkle to this which is
that according to an Cara's mayor the
assailant was an F eto member Fe T o is
short for Fethullah terrorist
organization which is a transnational
Islamic movement so again this does
raise the conversation that we've had
many many times of what is the
connection between individual acts of
violence or terror and religion in
particular in this case Islam that's
going to be a conversation that is
already being had unproductively in some
circles of the internet but that needs
to be had in a more productive way I'm
going to address that a little bit later
because there have been some on on the
Left who say individual acts of terror
perpetrated by Muslims no matter what
they say don't actually have anything to
do with Islam I find that incredibly not
not only inaccurate but also it's sort
of like burying your head in the sand to
the extent that we have to be able to
discuss all aspects of active terror
active violence political conflicts
geopolitical conflicts etc and I think
that out of hand saying Islam is not a
factor here and it should just simply
does not need to be discussed remember
we're talking about an assailant who
allegedly yelled Alou
Akbar who was angry about Muslims being
killed in a particular theater and to
ignore that reality is not going to get
us closer to any solutions I'm going to
talk about that a little bit later
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated